Hello everybody, this is Dr. Cutters again. Welcome to module two of the frequency healing course
This module we're going to be talking about purchasing a rife machine
We sell the true rife you may have already purchased a different type of rife machine
I understand so let's just go over this so you understand my logic in this and and
What we are currently doing so
so
In my mind there's four criteria
That maybe even more but at least four criteria that have to fit into a good rife machine
Whether I'll spend my buddy on a rife machine
Understand again that we use the true rife
Most of my adult children have a true rife at home that they use for their children
We have 20 grand children currently at this making of this video and more added every year
So I want my kids to be able to have a piece of
A sheetery that's going to help their children my grandchildren
Be as keep as healthy as possible and do well in times that they're struggling all kids go through different
disease processes different microbes that you're dealing with
different
You know things that they struggle with and they have a
Some modalities at home could be super beneficial to help them get through those things
so by four criteria what I'm looking at
A rife machine are as follows number one. It has to have enough power to penetrate
So there's rife machines that are on the market that are a little handheld devices that you stick at your pocket similar to a tens unit
And it's not really putting out enough
Power to really penetrate the body to affect the different organs
Again, this is my opinion that I'm not selling any specific
Piece of machinery that I get a cell cut from the company or anything like that and I get
Different companies tried to push me to buy different different modalities and sell to our patients
That um that I just I know I might look at them try them and I'm just not impressed
So in this whole course, I mean we do sell different pdf devices
We sell different light therapy devices that are done rife
We sell the rife machine. We sell um we don't sell lasers
Because they just get too expensive
but um
We you know recommend different lasers and ultrasound and electrical frequency devices
I think electrical frequency can be extremely beneficial using a tens unit can cost you a 50 bucks on
An Amazon to buy a tens unit and they're just great little devices when you got musculoskeletal
Soaredness from out shovel either or something like that
You hurt your back everybody should have a tens unit at home
But we're talking about rife machines
It has to have the power to penetrate the body and that really narrows it down to
Just a few that are on the market
If you look up and you do a search and I want to buy a rife machine
There's a there's no there's no patented of the name rife
It's the person's name that you know really
You know got
The done the research in the 20s and 30s and I'm sure you've watched the videos in module one
So anybody can say hey, this is a great rife machine and there's companies that just lie through their blast and teeth
To get you to buy a piece of machinery and I just don't like that
I just don't like that type of sales even if they have a great piece of equipment
When they're just kind of sneaky and
Lying and making claims that they shouldn't make I don't want everything to do with them
And there's a company in Canada that sells rife machines. I just want everything to do with them
They just do a lot of really shady business practices and
Life is too short to be
You know to be tied into a company like that. So I just won't have anything to do with them
So a it has to have the power to penetrate be it has to use light
Well, we're talking about rife machine
By definition of rife and I know this is just my definition
But if it's not using light frequencies, it's not a rife
There's machines out there the GB 4000 if you just buy them just the GB 4000 without the boba here's holding those two little
Electrodes to me. That's not a rife you want it is too. It's using frequencies
It's a rife just use frequencies at different times. That's fine
But I'm saying my definition. It's using the it's using light
So if you have a GB 4000 go by a boba
The GB 4000 with the boba is a great machine
So use that. That's a fantastic machine. It has plenty of power. It's using light
I have a GB 4000
We we saw people in our office. We had GB 4000s that we'd use also along with the true rife
But true rife is easier to use it. It fits these next two criteria
So the GB 4000 fits the power to penetrate fits the light if you have a boba
But now you get into programmability and the arguable
Think about this with the GB 4000 as it is programmable. Yeah, but it's like using DOS
Programming it's ridiculous. It's just sit there and punch it each different. It's just a pain in the
tail to program
We programmed it for people. I don't like to do it and get to the point where I just don't want to do it anymore
so
Has to be easily programmed. It has to be programmable in a way that you can that you could
That you can run
Different sweep programs with it so you can sweep through different frequencies as different microbes
tend to try to stay alive and they can morph their frequencies
Things like lime bacteria and colon infections can do that quite readily. So it's you have to you know
There's a little bit of an art to be able to kill these little buggers
But so it has to be programmable. It has to be easily changed. The program has to be easily updated
And then lastly and there may be more like I said, but it has to be easy to use
so one of the
Problems with the GB 4000s a little bit more high tech type thing be not high tech because it's actually lower tech
And that makes it a little bit more difficult to use
Where the true rife is just so simple to use just to turn it on and find a program comes with
2500 programs pre-programmed in it that I write specific programs depending on the person's problem
So it makes it super super simple to use. I use the true rife every night
And that's what's got me through my cancer. I'm convinced of it
No, there's a grace of God. So those are the criteria that I look for. This is the true rife
Currently the model is the f122
And we always use whatever the latest model is so this is the newest the greatest
Um, and the best one out there right now it comes in a package like this
Where it has the true rife it has another has the foot bath apparatus called the iron pro wave
So that serves as a detox tool and to be able to
get the using lies the higher frequencies in the
millions of hertz
category
And it comes with the ground-dead pad that you use when you use the foot bath apparatus
And we always sell it with the crystal tube. So we use the crystal hammer bulb with it
You can't see it. It's kind of tucked behind the machine in this picture here
But the crystal hammer bulb is an upgrade. We just get all of them with the crystal hammer
So if you're my one from us, you're going to get the crystal hammer bulb with it
It's just better. It can help split frequencies if you're dealing with the different microbes and stuff
And you know, these cancers could work their frequencies arguably too
So it just gives just an extra added coverage
It's a great
Abundal there
From true rife
So this is what we use if you had to purchase it a rife from us. This is the true rife
And this is what we'll be talking about in this module and I have some videos on why I like the true rife
And I go with the more detail than I have on this
But look through all these things. Don't be discouraged if you already purchased some other rife machine
This whole course is going to help you utilize that utilize those things in a more wise
Matter as well
But it is more focused the rife piece of this of these modules are focused on the true rife because that's what I recommend
so
Hope this is a blessed to you. No, I'll be praying for you. I ask that you continue to pray for us
And look at this module remember these are all livid modules is I learned more things and add more information and more knowledge
These modules will be added to so come back and check them. All right. Blessings. Bye